60 years ago today a young woman spoke
about the speed of technological change
but she presented the first television
broadcast of its kind she described the
moment as a landmark television has made
it possible for many of you to see me in
your homes on Christmas day my own
family often gather round to watch
television as they are at this moment
and that is how I imagine you now six
decades on the presenter has evolved
somewhat as has the technology she
described back then who could have
imagined that people would one day be
watching this on laptops and mobile
phones as some of you are today but I'm
also struck by something that hasn't
changed that whatever the technology
many of you will be watching this at
home we think of our homes as places of
warmth familiarity and love
I've shared stories and memories
which is perhaps why at this time of
year so many returned to where they grew
up there is a Timeless Simplicity to the
pull of home
to celebrate the life of Queen Elizabeth
II we've put together a list of some of
her most inspiring clips and moments I
hope you enjoy
for many the idea of home we reaches
Beyond a physical building
to Hometown or City
this Christmas I think of London and
Manchester
whose powerful identities Shone through
over the past 12 months in the face of
appalling attacks
in Manchester those targeted included
children who had gone to see their
favorite singer
a few days after the bombing I had the
privilege of meeting some of the young
survivors and their parents so you'll
come especially for the concert yeah the
birthday person what was it you're right
very scary
very Wicked um
Target that sort of thing yeah yes
that's awful but uh hopefully it'll mend
it's very interesting how everybody has
United haven't they yeah well it's been
amazing
I describe that hospital visit as a
privilege
because the patients I met were an
example to us all
showing extraordinary bravery and
resilience
indeed many of those who survived the
attack
came together just days later for a
benefit concert
it was a powerful reclaiming of the
ground
and of the city those young people call
home
we expect our homes to be a place of
safety Sanctuary even
which makes it all the more shocking
when the Comfort they provide is
shattered
a few weeks ago the Prince of Wales
visited the Caribbean in the aftermath
of hurricanes that destroyed entire
communities
and here in London who can forget the
sheer awfulness of the grindful tower
far
our thoughts and prayers are with all
those who died and those who lost so
much
and we are indebted to members of the
Emergency Services who risk their own
lives this past year saving others
many of them of course will not be at
home today because they are working to
protect us
reflecting on these events makes me
grateful for the blessings of Home and
Family
and in particular for 70 years of
marriage
I don't know that anyone had invented
the term Platinum for a 70th wedding
anniversary when I was born
you weren't expected to be around that
long
even Prince Philip has decided it's time
to slow down a little
having as he economically put it down
his bed
but I know his support and unique sense
of humor will remain as strong as ever
as we enjoy spending time this Christmas
with our family
and look forward to welcoming new
members into it next year as a child I
never imagined that one day a man would
walk on the moon
yet this year we marked the 50th
anniversary of the famous Apollo 11
mission
still looking very good here go
the eagle has landed
as there's historic pictures were beamed
back to Earth
millions of us sat transfixed to our
television screens as we watched Neil
Armstrong taking a small step for man
and a giant leap for mankind
and indeed for womankind
it's a reminder for us all the giant
leaps often start with small steps
this year we marked another important
anniversary D-Day
on the 6th of June 1944 some 156
000 British Canadian and American forces
landed in northern France
it was the largest ever Seaborn Invasion
and was delayed due to bad weather
I will remember the look of concern on
my father's face
he knew the secret D-Day plans but could
of course share that burden with no one
for the 75th anniversary of that
decisive battle
in a true Spirit of reconciliation
those who had formerly been sworn
anyways came together in Friendly
commemorations either side of the
channel
putting past differences behind them
such reconciliation seldom happens
overnight
it takes patience and time to rebuild
Trust
and progress often comes through small
steps
since the end of the second world war
many Charities groups and organizations
have worked to promote peace and unity
around the world
bringing together those who have been on
opposing sides
by being willing to put past differences
behind us and move forward together
we honor the freedom and democracy once
won for us at so greater cost
the challenges many people face today
may be different to those ones faced by
my generation
but I have been struck by how new
generations have brought a similar sense
of purpose
to issues such as protecting our
environment and our climate
my family and I are also inspired by the
men and women of our emergency services
and Armed Forces
and at Christmas we remember all those
on duty at home and abroad who are
helping those in need and keeping us and
our families safe and secure
200 years on from the birth of my great
great grandmother Queen Victoria
Prince Philip and I have been delighted
to welcome our eighth great grandchild
into our family
of course at the heart of the Christmas
story lies the birth of a child
seemingly small and insignificant step
overlooked by many in Bethlehem
but in time through his teaching and by
his example
Jesus Christ would show the world how
small steps taken in faith and in Hope
can overcome long-held differences and
deep-seated divisions to bring Harmony
and understanding
many of us already tried to follow in
his footsteps
the path of course is not always smooth
and May at times this year have felt
quite bumpy but small steps can make a
world of difference
as Christmas stoned Church congregations
around the world joined in singing It
Came Upon the Midnight Clear
like many Timeless carols it speaks not
just to the coming of Jesus Christ into
a divided World many years ago
but also of the relevance even today of
the Angel's message of peace and good
will
it's a timely reminder of what positive
things can be achieved when people set
aside past differences and come together
in the spirit of friendship and
Reconciliation
and as we all look forward to the start
of a new decade it's worth remembering
that it is often the small steps not the
giant leaps that bring about the most
lasting change there was a time when
British Olympic medal winners became
household names
because there were so few of them
but the 67 medals at this year's games
in Rio
and 147 of the Paralympics
meant that the GB medalist reception at
Buckingham Palace was a crowded unhappy
event
throughout the Commonwealth that were
equally joyful celebrations
Grenada the Bahamas Jamaica and New
Zealand won more medals per head of
population than any other countries
many of this year's winners spoke of
being inspired by athletes of previous
generations
inspiration fed their aspiration
and having discovered abilities they
scarcely knew they had these athletes
are now inspiring others
a few months ago I saw inspiration of a
different kind
when I opened the new Cambridge base of
the East anglian air ambulance
where Prince William works as a
helicopter pilot
it was not hard to be moved by the
dedication of the highly skilled doctors
paramedics and crew
who were called out on average five
times a day
but to be inspirational you don't have
to save lives or win medals
I often draw strength from meeting
ordinary people doing extraordinary
things
volunteers carers Community organizers
and good neighbors
unsung heroes whose quiet dedication
makes them special
they are an inspiration to those who
know them
and their lives frequently embody a
truth expressed by Mother Teresa from
this year Saint Teresa of Calcutta
she once said not all of us can do great
things
but we can do small things with great
love
this has been the experience of two
remarkable organizations
the Duke of edinburgh's award and the
prince's Trust
which are 60 and 40 years old this year
these started as small initiatives
but have grown Beyond any expectations
and continue to transform young people's
lives
tomorrow my 90th birthday
volunteers and supporters of the 600
Charities of which I have been Patron
came to a lunch in the mail
many of these organizations are modest
in size
but inspire me with the work they do
from giving friendship and support to
our veterans the elderly or the bereaved
to championing music and dance providing
Animal Welfare
or protecting our fields and forests
their selfless devotion and generosity
of spirit is an example to us all
when people face a challenge
they sometimes talk about taking a deep
breath to find courage or strength
in fact the word inspire literally means
to breathe in
but even with the inspiration of others
it's understandable that we sometimes
think the world's problems are so big
that we can do little to help
on our own we cannot end Wars or wipe
out Injustice
but the cumulative impact of thousands
of small acts of goodness can be bigger
than we imagine
at Christmas our attention is drawn to
the birth of a baby some 2 000 years ago
it was the humblest of beginnings
and his parents Joseph and Mary did not
think they were important
Jesus Christ lived obscurely for most of
his life and never traveled far
he was maligned and rejected by many
though he had done no wrong
and yet billions of people now follow
his teaching and find in him The Guiding
Light for their lives
I am one of them because Christ's
example helps me see the value of doing
small things with great love
whoever does them and whatever they
themselves believe
the message of Christmas reminds us that
inspiration is a gift to be given as
well as received
and that love begins small but always
grows this is a duty I'm especially
happy to discharge as the impact of the
environment on human progress was a
subject close to the heart of my dear
late husband Prince Philip the Duke of
Edinburgh
I remember well that in 1969 he told an
academic Gathering
if the world pollution situation is not
critical at the moment
it is as certain as anything can be that
the situation will become increasingly
intolerable within a very short time
if we fail to cope with this challenge
all the other problems will pale into
insignificance
it is a source of great pride to me that
the leading role my husband played in
encouraging people to protect our
fragile planet
lives on through the work of our eldest
son Charles and his eldest son William
I could not be more proud of them
indeed I have drawn great comfort and
inspiration from the Relentless
enthusiasm of people of all ages
especially the Young
in calling for everyone to play their
part
in the coming days the world has the
chance to join in the shared objective
of creating a safer Stabler future for
our people and for the planet on which
we depend
none of us underestimates the challenges
ahead
but history has shown
that when Nations come together in
common cause there is always room for
hope
working side by side we have the ability
to solve the most insurmountable
problems
and to triumph over the greatest of
adversities
for more than 70 years I have been lucky
to meet and to know many of the world's
great leaders
and I have perhaps come to understand a
little about what made them special
it has sometimes been observed that what
leaders do for their people today
is government and politics
but what they do for the people of
tomorrow
that is statesmanship
I for one hope that this conference will
be one of those rare occasions
where everyone will have the chance to
rise above the politics of the moment
and Achieve true statesmanship
it is the hope of many that the legacy
of this Summit
written in history books yet to be
printed
will describe you as the leaders who did
not pass up the opportunity
and that you answer the call of those
future Generations
that you left this conference as a
community of Nations
with the determination a desire and a
plan
to address the impact of climate change
and to recognize that the time for words
has now moved to the time for action
of course the benefits of such actions
will not be there to enjoy for all of us
here today
we none of us will live forever
but we are doing this not for ourselves
but for our children and our children's
children and those who will follow in
their footsteps
and so I wish you every good fortune in
the significant Endeavor it it's
inevitable that I should seem a rather
remote figure to many of you
a successor to the kings and queens of
History
someone whose face may be familiar in
newspapers and films
but who never really touches your
personal lives
but now at least for a few minutes I
welcome you to the Peace of my own home
that it's possible for some of you to
see me today
is just another example of the speed at
which things are changing all around us
because of these changes
I'm not surprised that many people feel
lost and unable to decide what to hold
on to and what to discard
how to take advantage of the new life
without losing the best of the old
but it's not the new inventions which
are the difficulty
the trouble is caused by unthinking
people
who carelessly throw away ageless ideals
as if they were old and outworn
machinery
they would have religion thrown aside
morality and personal and public life
made meaningless
honesty counted as foolishness
and self-interest set up in place of
self-restraint
at this critical moment in our history
we will certainly lose the trust and
respect of the world
if we just abandon those fundamental
principles
which guided the men and women who built
the greatness of this country and
Commonwealth
today we need a special kind of Courage
not the kind needed in battle
but a kind which makes us stand up for
everything that we know is right
everything that is true and honest
we need the kind of Courage that can
withstand the subtle Corruption of the
cynics
so that we can show the world that we
are not afraid of the future
it has always been easier to hate and
destroy
to build and to cherish is much more
difficult
that's why we can take a pride in the
new Commonwealth we are building
this year Ghana and Malaya joined our
Brotherhood
both these countries are entirely
self-governing
both achieve their new status amicably
and peacefully
this Advance is a wonderful tribute to
the efforts of men of Goodwill who have
worked together as friends
and I welcome these two countries with
all my heart
last October I opened the new Canadian
Parliament
and as you know this was the first time
that any Sovereign had done so in Ottawa
once again I was overwhelmed by the
loyalty and enthusiasm of my Canadian
people
also during 1957 my husband and I paid
visits to Portugal France Denmark and
the United States of America
in each case the arrangements and
formalities were managed with great
skill
but no one could have managed the
welcome we received from the people
in each country I was welcomed as head
of the Commonwealth and as your
representative
these nations are our friends
largely because we've always tried to do
our best to be honest and kindly
and because we have tried to stand up
for what we believe to be right
in the old days
the monocleid his soldiers on the
battlefield and his leadership at all
times was close and personal
today things are very different
I cannot lead you into battle
I do not give you laws old Minister
Justice
but I can do something else
I can give you my heart
and my devotion to these old Islands and
all the peoples of our Brotherhood of
Nations
I believe in our qualities and in our
strength
I believe that together we can set an
example to the world
which will encourage upright people
everywhere
I would like to read you a few lines
from Pilgrim's Progress
because I'm sure we can say with Mr
Valiant for truth these words
though with great difficulty I am God
hither
yet now I do not repent me of all the
trouble I have been at to arrive where I
am
My Sword I give to him that shall
succeed me in my pilgrimage
and my courage and skill to him that can
get it
my marks and scars I carry with me
to be a witness for me that I have
fought his battles
who now will be my rewarder although
it's a time of great happiness and good
cheer for many
Christmas can be hard for those who have
lost loved ones
this year especially I understand why
but for me in the months since the death
of my beloved Philip I have drawn great
comfort from the warmth and affection of
the many tributes to his life and work
from around the country the Commonwealth
and the world
his sense of service intellectual
curiosity
and capacity to squeeze fun out of any
situation were all irrepressible
that mischievous inquiring twinkle was a
Sprite at the end as when I first set
eyes on him
good life of course consists of final
partings as well as first meetings
and as much as I and my family miss him
I know he would want us to enjoy
Christmas
we felt his presence As We Lay Millions
around the world readied ourselves for
Christmas
while covid again means we can't
celebrate quite as we may have wished
we can still enjoy the many happy
traditions
be it the singing of carols
as long as the tune is well known
decorating the tree
giving and receiving presence
or watching a favorite film where we
already know the ending
it's no surprise that families so often
treasure their Christmas routines
we see our own children and their
families embrace the roles traditions
and values that means so much to us as
these are passed from one generation to
the next
sometimes being updated for Changing
Times
I see it in my own family and it is a
source of great happiness
Prince Philip was always mindful of this
sense of passing the battle
that's why he created the Duke of
edinburgh's award
which offers young people throughout the
Commonwealth and Beyond the chance of
exploration and adventure
it remains an astonishing success
grounded in his faith in the future
he was also an early champion of taking
seriously our stewardship of the
environment
and I am proud beyond words that his
pioneering work has been taken on and
magnified by our eldest son Charles and
his eldest son William
admirably supported by Camilla and
Catherine most recently at the cop
climate change Summit in Glasgow
next summer we look forward to the
Commonwealth Games
the better is currently traveling the
length and breadth of the Commonwealth
heading towards Birmingham a Beacon of
Hope on its Journey
it will be a chance to celebrate the
achievements of athletes and the coming
together of like-minded Nations
and February just six weeks from now
we'll see the start of my Platinum
Jubilee year
which I hope will be an opportunity for
people everywhere to enjoy a sense of
togetherness
a chance to give thanks for the enormous
changes of the last 70 years
social scientific and cultural
and also to look ahead with confidence
I'm sure someone somewhere today will
remark that Christmas is a time for
children
it's an engaging truth but only half the
story
perhaps it's truer to say that Christmas
can speak to the child within us all
adults when we're done with worries
sometimes fail to see the joy in simple
things where children do not
and for me and my family even with one
familiar laugh missing this year there
will be joy in Christmas as we have the
chance to reminisce
and see Anew The Wonder of the festive
season
Through The Eyes of our young children
of whom we were delighted to welcome
formal this year
they teach us all a lesson
just as the Christmas story does
that in the birth of a child there is a
new dawn with endless potential
it is this Simplicity of the Christmas
story that makes it so universally
appealing
simple happenings that form the starting
point of the life of Jesus
a man whose teachings have been handed
down from generation to generation
and have been the Bedrock of my faith
his birth marked a new beginning
as the Carol says
the hopes and fears of all the years are
met in thee tonight some cultures
believe a long life brings wisdom
I'd like to think so
perhaps part of that wisdom is to
recognize some of life's baffling
paradoxes
such as the way human beings have a huge
propensity for good
and yet a capacity for evil
even the power of Faith which frequently
inspires great generosity and
self-sacrifice
can fall victim to tribalism
but through the many changes I have seen
over the years
faith family and friendship have been
not only a constant for me but a source
of personal comfort and reassurance
in April the Commonwealth heads of
government met in London
my father welcomed just eight countries
to the first such meetings in 1948.
now the Commonwealth includes 53
countries with 2.4 billion people
third of the world's population
its strength lies in the bonds of
affection it promotes
and a common desire to live in a better
more peaceful world
even with the most deeply held
differences
treating the other person with respect
and as a fellow human being is always a
good first step towards greater
understanding
indeed the Commonwealth Games held this
year on Australia's Gold Coast our known
University as the friendly games
because of that emphasis on Goodwill and
mutual respect
the Christmas story retains its appeal
since it doesn't provide theoretical
explanations for the puzzles of life
instead it's about the birth of a child
and the hope that birth two thousand
years ago brought to the world
only a few people acknowledge Jesus when
he was born
now billions follow him
I believe his message of peace on Earth
and Good Will to all is never out of
date
it can be heeded by everyone
it's needed as much as ever I speak to
you today the same are as my father did
exactly 75 years ago
his message then was a salute to the men
and women at home and abroad who had
sacrificed so much in pursuit of what he
rightly called a great Deliverance
the war had been a total war
it had affected everyone and no one was
immune from its impact
whether it be the men and women called
up to serve
families separated from each other
all people asked to take up new rules
and skills to support the war effort
all had a part to play
at the start the Outlook seemed bleak
the end distant the outcome uncertain
but we kept faith that the cause was
right
and this belief as my father noted in
his broadcast carried us through
never give up never despair that was the
message of ye day
I vividly remember the jubilant scenes
my sister and I witnessed with our
parents in Winston Churchill from the
balcony of Buckingham Palace
the sins of joy in the crowds who
gathered outside and across the country
was profound
the world we celebrated the victory in
Europe we knew there would be further
sacrifice
it was not until August that fighting in
the Far East ceased and the war finally
ended
many people laid down their lives in
that terrible conflict
they fought so we could live in peace at
home and abroad
they died so we could live as three
people in a world of free Nations
they risked all so our families and
neighborhoods could be safe
we should and will remember them
as I now reflect on my father's words
and the joyous celebrations which some
of us experienced firsthand
I'm thankful for the strength and
courage that the United Kingdom the
Commonwealth and all our allies
displayed
the wartime generation knew that the
best way to honor those who did not come
back from the war
was to ensure that it didn't happen
again
the greatest tribute to their sacrifice
is that countries who were once sworn
enemies are now friends
working side by side for the peace
health and prosperity of us all
today it may seem hard that we cannot
mark the special anniversary as we would
wish
instead we remember from our homes and
our doorsteps
but our streets are not empty they are
filled with the love and the care that
we have for each other
and when I look at our country today and
see what we are willing to do to project
and support one another
I say with pride
that we are still a nation those brave
Soldiers Sailors and Airmen would
recognize and admire
I send my warmest good wishes to you all
in wishing you all good evening
I feel that I am speaking to friends and
companions who have shared with my
sister and myself many are Happy
Children's are
thousands of you in this country have
had to leave your homes and be separated
from your fathers and mothers
My Sister Margaret Rose and I feel so
much for you
as we know from experience what it means
to be away from those we love most of
all
[Applause]
living in new surroundings we send a
message of true sympathy and at the same
time we would like to thank the kind
people who have welcomed you to their
homes in the country
all of us children who are still at home
think continually of our friends and
relations who have gone overseas
who have traveled thousands of miles to
find a wartime home and a kindly welcome
in Canada Australia New Zealand South
Africa and the United States of America
my sister and I feel we know quite a lot
about these countries
our father and mother have so often
talked to us of their visits to
different parts of the world
so it is not difficult for us to picture
the sort of life you are all leading and
to think of all the new sights you must
be seeing and the adventures you must be
having
but I am sure that you too are often
thinking of the old country
I know you won't forget us
it is just because we are not forgetting
you that I want on behalf of all the
children at home
to send you our love and best wishes
to you and to your kind hosts as well
before I finish I can truthfully say to
you all
that we children at home are full of
cheerfulness and courage
we are trying to do all we can to help
our Gallant Sailors soldiers and Airmen
and we are trying to to Bear our own
share of the danger and sadness of War
we know every one of us but in the end
all will be well
for God will care for us and give us
Victory and peace
and when peace comes
remember it will be for us the children
of today to make the World of Tomorrow a
better and happier place
to see the top 10 we did on Princess
Diana check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I don't
think I am I'm a perfectionist with
myself but not necessarily with
everybody else and those stories arose a
long time ago and have kept coming out
again and again but I don't think um